you made a great prediction last hour
that tom brady will be
making it known where he's going to be
playing early in that legal tampering
window and the patriots have a limited
window of opportunity to try to keep him
and uh chris you know the big question
is will they do it and what else will
they be doing to do it and there was a
report yesterday from albert breer of si
that the patriots are looking into the
possibility of trading for receivers in
tight ends and presumably that would be
to make it more enticing for tom brady
to stay right where he is no doubt i
mean it's gonna make it more enticing
for tom brady or if tom brady did leave
town which i don't expect him to it's
gonna make it better on that next guy
who comes in at quarterback either way
but we know
you know new england needs improvements
at these two positions i mean their
dynasty
is built on you know some good receiver
play with a great tight end we know
whether it was you know i don't want to
say good receiver play i should say
great whether it's dion branch edelman
wes welker randy moss i mean they've had
some good ones there and it's a tough
combination to stop with that offense
and then a tight end working down the
middle now mike there's some interesting
names i think out there that could be
had as far as via the trade you know
we've heard rumors of you know stefan
diggs okay i'm still not going to say
that doesn't happen i know minnesota's
saying they're they're stefan diggs and
spielman told us right they've never
said he is a minnesota viking right no
no no remember i said look into the
camera and say we have no intent to str
to trade stephon diggs and spielman said
stefan diggs is a minnesota viking and
you said that meant absolutely not
batman absolutely nothing that's right
he is a minnesota viking until like you
say he's not right so you think about
him
stefan diggs aj green i think that's got
to be a team that new england probably
would have called about sammy watkins we
know that kansas city most likely not
gonna have him back especially not not
at 16 million dollars and then you got
guys like hey i don't know if they would
go down to brandon cook's lane once
again i know they've had him before uh
al shawn jeffrey with the eagles that's
an interesting one so i think there is
some interesting plays to be had and i
think the you know the wide receiver
market in general could be interesting
here but the the patriots have to
improve that area of their football team
if they want to take that next step
again and be back in the afc
championship and in the super bowl
yeah i mean regardless of whether tom
brady or anyone else is the quarterback
you need better receivers and tight ends
you need someone chris who commands
double coverage
down the field yes every once in a while
you see double coverage on julian
edelman but when you're bunched into the
slot like that it's very easy for a guy
to peel off you want someone who's going
to stretch and pull the take the top off
of the defense as people like to say you
want to have two guys following him deep
down the field so everything else
underneath opens up with single coverage
yeah a hundred percent and new england
is the king of doing that and then when
they get two guys like that a tight end
and let's say a receiver and then they
usually have a pass catching back to
come out of the backfield a lot james
white or you know the deon lewis's and
all that you know then they become very
tough to stop because now you're going
whoa there's a receiver on the outside
and work in the middle of the field well
the tight end they really know how to
get the ball to him in a whole lot of
different ways and then they'll have the
running back come out of the backfield
and work the underneath coverage and
that's what makes new england you know
special that way and that's what makes
them so dominant for so many years they
usually had that type of combination you
know it was gronkowski and edelman
towards the end in the middle it was
kind of like randy moss and wes welker
together they did the same thing they
just did it a little bit of a different
way you know in the early years he had
the ben watson the daniel graham and the
dion branch conversations and troy brown
so you know they definitely need to
improve that area of their football team
if they want to make a serious run
they're just you're not going to beat
kansas city 17 to 14 in the playoffs
that's just not going to happen you
better have some firepower at your
disposal yeah and and look
it may be that they are looking into
making these trades
not necessarily to convince brady to
stay but to shore up some weaknesses in
the event that they have to prove they
can win without him right because
they're going to want to show that we
can do it without tom brady and uh
they know tom brady is going to be
trying to show that he can do it without
them and you know chris the delay
by two days of the cba vote right from
thursday night to saturday night that
really cuts down the window that the
patriots have to get something worked
out before the legal tampering period
opens they're gonna have all day sunday
24 hours sunday and 12 hours monday to
work out a deal with tom brady once they
know what the rules will be because
we're not going to know whether we're
operating under the rules of the current
cba or the new cba until midnight or
however long it takes to process the
votes on sunday morning after the voting
is done i'd like to think it's
instantaneous since the voting is being
done digitally but that's when they'll
know and that window has now been
shrunken by two days for the patriots
and tom brady to work something out
that's an impediment to this and we need
to keep that in mind too because they
have to work out a contract and deal
with that 13 plus million in dead money
that tom brady is going to count for if
he becomes a free agent on wednesday
yeah right right well that changes
things and you know i think the one
thing that you know jumped out about
what you said first off is i i think
that's very real
that brady and belichick
you know if they split their their their
you know different ways here hey the the
war is on i mean this is going to be a
race to prove who was the more important
guy i think both of these guys love
their time together but they're
extremely competitive and i think they
realize that they're synonymous in a lot
of ways and i think both of them would
like to show like hey i know the other
guy i was with is really great but he's
not that great i can win without him i
almost wouldn't be shocked if new
england ended up going harder in free
agency if they lost brady because then
they know oh man we're going to lose
some inventory in our offense we can't
expect somebody to come in here and do
all of that stuff and i think they'll
overcompensate for the loss of brady to
want to show that hey we're still a
really good team and we can win without
them to where they might make more
aggressive moves if they lose them than
they do if they necessarily bring them
back
chris it may be the kick in the ass that
everyone needs right yeah for brady and
for bella checking the patriots i mean
after 20 years this is the kind of thing
that gets everybody fired up again like
brady i'm gonna go prove to you guys
that i can do it and belichick i'm gonna
prove to the world that i didn't just
luck into a sixth round draft pick who
ended up being one of the great
quarterbacks of all time if not the
greatest quarterback of all time and
otherwise i wouldn't have a single
lombardi trophy so it is going to make
things interesting and that's why i kind
of like him to stay in the afc i want
there to be a greater chance of his path
crossing with bradys and vice versa uh
and uh if he leaves that's going to be a
big part of it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports